JEFF SMITH: Music, ultimately,
is a global medium.
And we want to connect
the world through
this expressive medium.
We don't think there's anybody
out there that
doesn't like music.
PRERNA GUPTA:
[SINGING "AMAZING GRACE"]
JEFF SMITH: Smule's the leader
in mobile, social music.
We'd like a billion people to
figure out how to make music
together using mobile devices.
That's one of the reasons why
we're extremely excited about
the Android platform.
PRERNA GUPTA: We were amazed at
how many more users we were
able to reach in such a
short period of time.
JEFF SMITH: We're now north of
12 million monthly users
hitting our products, and that
compares with about 2 and 1/2
million a year ago, before
we were on Android and
GooglePlay.
PRERNA GUPTA: It's
record growth.
It's the fastest growth
we've ever seen.
JODI ROPERT: And we have over
10 million installs now.
And that's been only
about three months.
80% of our users for Songify
are outside of the US.
Markets like Russia and Brazil
and India and Malaysia.
AutoRap was the first app that
we launched simultaneously
across platforms, and we were
amazed with what we saw.
Not only did it allow us to
reach more people, there was
this incredible word
of mouth growth.
There was this halo effect.
We spent a lot of time trying
to create landing pages and
images and marketing materials
that allow customers to
quickly understand what our apps
deliver and get excited
about it and then install
the application.
When customers install our apps
from a YouTube video,
they tend to be two to three
times more valuable.
They are more engaged, they
stay for longer, and they
monetize better.
PRERNA GUPTA: I think AutoRap
has been a great example of
how the ability to update
immediately has really helped
us with our product quality.
Our rating for AutoRap has been
consistently higher every
single day, basically, since
we've launched on GooglePlay.
And that's directly a result
of the fact that we can
respond immediately.
When a bug comes up, and when
we're getting certain feedback
from users, we can fix that
in a day and launch it.
JEFF SMITH: We want to bring
music back to its roots of a
social, interactive,
expressive medium.
And that can only happen if we
bring everybody with us.
And that's one of the reasons
why we're so excited about
Android and GooglePlay.
We think we open up this
experience to the globe
through this platform.